Nightengale island nearby tristan da
cunha are some of the remotest islands
in the world over a thousand miles in
any direction from inhabited lands as
such these were some of the least
polluted environments on earth that was
until last week when the MV Olivas
sailing from Brazil crashed headlong
into the island and spilled over 800
tons of fuel oil into the sea
nightingale Island is a vital breeding
ground for the already endangered
northern Rockhopper penguin
and now the islands entire population is
at risk
I arrived over a week after the incident
had occurred and yet I was still among
the very first humans to see the full
extent of this horrific event I saw
hundreds of rockhopper penguins covered
in sticky black peel oil several of them
were preening themselves trying to get
the oil off the feathers in the process
and destiny oil which is poisonous to
the birds fortunately a relief crew
arrived a few days ago from South Africa
but still there are only a dozen of them
and they are confronting a tragedy this
far beyond the scope of a few hands
luckily yesterday over 750 fuel covered
Penguins were collected and are in the
process of getting things now there's an
added element of tragedy for the people
of Tristan a population of less than 300
we have always prided themselves in the
pollution-free stage of their islands I
also noticed several baby fur seal pups
born this last season with patches of
oil on their fur and with obvious
effects from the spill still it's the
Penguins who take priority since they
are endangered the remaining population
has been penned in to prevent them from
going back into the sea this was such a
difficult thing to witness and I hope
that I never have to see it again